[Musique]
au 19e siècle à l'hôtel tatin de la mote
buverron les sœurs tatin accueillaient
les chasseurs bourgeois l'aîné gérit la
clientèle la cadette Stéphanie elle
était au fourneau un jour dans la
précipitation elle enfourna des pommes
jeelle suis dit mince j'ai oublié la
pâte donc elle rajouta la pâte
par-dessus elle se dit avec un peu de
chance ça va peut-être être bon mais
c'était excellent parce que ainsi est né
la tarte tatin un succès mondial pour la
mote beuverron et aujourd'hui à l'hôtel
tatin grâce à Anaïs et son équipe vous
allez voir de Stéphanie tatin a
peut-être disparu mais sa tarte a laissé
une trace gourmande dans l'histoire des
desserts salut Camie Anaïs comment ça va
ça va et toi tu sais quelle est la tarte
préférée du chanteur Renault non mais tu
vas me le dire et ben la tarte tatteint
justement parce que c'est pas l'homme
qui prend la merre c'est la mer qui
prend
l'homme tu es quand même au courant
qu'on est dans la maison des sorttin
ouais et il y a les esprits des sortatin
bien sûr et on risque de te jeter un
sortiè bah
regarde-toi
alors je vais te faire découvrir la
pièce emblématique de la maison ah donc
ça c'est vraiment le four des des sures
àtin c'est ça par contre Anaïs comment
je fais pour me sortir de ce sortilège
il va falloir que tu cuisines une tarte
àtin si tu l'as réussi ça va t'enever le
sortilège sur tatin un peu afro mais
c'est moderne c'est dans l'air du
Caroline et Stéphanie voilà allez au par
en cuisine allez suis-moi je
t'emmène faut que tu me sorses de là max
comment on fait une tarte tatin alors là
tu as le sucre donc je mets là-dedans
ouais ok plaque du haut et tu allumes et
tu attends que ça caraminise et ben
écoutez on va attendre
alors ça va impeccable ça va être bon là
non on va regarder et là c'est bon là on
le quitte plus des yeux qu tu sais
quelle est la tarte préférée de ferur
non la tte tatin je je suis
libertine je suis une tatin très bonne
très bonne regarde-moi ça écoute tu t'en
sors pas trop mal c'estesprit des surtin
ça cette odeur extra 100 boule de glace
V attention très important ça faut
respecter s boules de glace vanille
crème fr un qui met une boule de glace
vanille en plus les sorttins étaient
très forte
ca voilà démonstration de force donc du
coup
ça d'ailleurs max tu nous viens de Brou
enire c'est ça
[Musique]
donc lui il va jamais sortir de sa tenue
des S alors là il va falloir dérouler la
ptein de la poser dessus on coupe sur
les
bords c'est gratuit pour l'Ingon ça très
agréable ce
bruit donc là on met au four oui on met
alors c'est parti c'est le moment
crucial les
amis
[Musique]
49 minutes B ben on va
attendre pouvez attendre chez vous aussi
bon l'émission est plus courte que 50
minutes mais attendez quand même autre
moment crucial le retournement de la
tarte ça juté
déjà je suis vraiment fier de ce qu'on a
fait fier de ce qu'on a accompli mais
peu importe ce est important c'est que
la tarte tatin c'est une tarte française
et ça faut être fier ta
[Musique]
tarte